amis téléspectateurs bonjour vous êtes
sur le plateau dès maintenant l'émission
qui revient avec plaisir et avec vous
sur l'actualité politique de la semaine
vous connaissez le principe hashtag et
maintenant si vous souhaitez réagir
aujourd'hui autour de cette table des
géants de l'analyse ils ont le fond ils
ont la forme ils ont de l'intelligence à
revendre avec nous aujourd'hui le
redoutable et le redouter Jean-Luc mano
ça va pas mal
en communication fondateur du cabinet
only conseil c'est une première pour
vous Olivier babo ravi de vous
accueillir bonjour Merci d'être
invitation président de l'Institut
sapiens vous êtes l'auteur du livre la
tyrannie du divertissement aux éditions
bûcher Chastel pierre Jacquemin le
bouillonnant Pierre Jacques moi et la
bonjour ça va bonjour Tout va bien c'est
très dacteur en chef au magazine
politique on va voir la une de la
semaine elle porte sur le service
national universel et c'est dérive que
vous dénoncez la percutante Astrid de
Vilaine est aussi avec nous aujourd'hui
bonjour Astrid chef du service politique
du offington pose vous avez écrit les
sept péchés capitaux de la gauche chez
Jean-Claude latesse dans cette émission
on se demandera si les réseaux sociaux
sont en train de nous rendre fou si
l'Italie est en train de banaliser
l'extrême droite tiens en parlant
d'extrême droite faut-il débattre avec
elle de tout n'importe où on essaiera
aussi de comprendre pourquoi la gauche a
tout raté dans cette séquence retraite
c'est en tout cas ce que nous disent les
derniers sondages mais d'abord c'est
ouvert merci président l'archet retour
sur la très longue semaine d'Emmanuel
Macron tout a commencé lundi par une
allocution dans laquelle nous assurer
qu'il allait reprendre la main après la
promulgation chaotique de la réforme des
retraites et puis et puis les événements
se sont un peu accélérés regardez nous
avons devant nous 100 jours
d'apaisement d'unité
d'ambition et d'action au service de la
France c'est notre devoir et je vous
fais confiance je nous fais confiance
[Musique]
tu comprends pas là-dedans
l'augmentation des cotisations
patronales une cassure aujourd'hui entre
Macron et les Français
inédite bon il y a déjà eu des
présidents de la République qui ont été
en divorce au total avec l'opinion mais
en général ça se fait à -1 an -1 an et
demi avant l'élection présidentielle ça
a été le cas pour Nicolas Sarkozy
peut-être un peu plus tôt pour François
Hollande ça a été le cas pour Jacques
Chirac à la fin de son mandat avec la
fameuse émission il dit à des jeunes je
vous comprends vraiment pas donc oui
c'est divorce ont eu lieu le problème
c'est que l'on est à -4 ans c'est ça qui
fait la décision la décision inédite
vous voyez aussi une rupture entre
Emmanuel Macron et les Français on a vu
plusieurs déplacements cette semaine
c'était compliqué
oui oui et puis ça dure en fait c'est à
dire que c'est pas de cette semaine
qu'on découvre cette fracture cette
difficulté qu'il a à renouer avec
l'opinion il n'a pas de majorité à
l'Assemblée il a toute l'Inter syndical
ado
donc ça fait beaucoup et puis je trouve
que cette déambulation ce retour sur le
terrain aurait pu se faire avec un peu
plus de modestie parce que c'est à dire
que vu la séquence c'est bien moi je
trouve de retourner sur le terrain c'est
important et je pense que c'est plutôt
la bonne option mais j'ai trouvé les les
déclarations du président de la
République quand même assez très sûr de
lui ce moquant voilà ou critiquant les
casseroles en faisant des blagues ou des
boutades qui sont à mon avis assez
inapproprié vu l'histoire politique de
la casserole qui remonte quand même au
19e siècle la Monarchie de Juillet
comme ça balayant d'un revers de main
l'analyse assez forte de Pierre
Rosanvallon là de nos plus grands
chercheurs et historiens sur la
démocratie en le traitant de militant
voilà je pense un petit peu plus de
recul sur ce qui se passe c'est à dire
une conditions de gens qui n'ont pas
grand chose à voir et qui sont très
offensés par cette réforme des retraites
Olivier même question rupture divorce
entre le président et les Français
rupture très aujourd'hui assez claire
aujourd'hui il est tombé au plus bas de
sa popularité mais au plus bas depuis
quand depuis les gilets jaunes ça veut
dire c'est déjà arrivé et moi je suis
toujours frappé par la capacité
d'amnésie qu'on a collectif sur les
sujets dont on parle à un moment donné
qui paraissent être le centre du monde
et puis en fait quelques mois après
alors quelques années après finalement
on est dans complètement autre chose et
c'est là où je pense qu'il a quand même
pas si mal joué avec son avec son avec
son discours alors attendez on va
revenir sur la question en tout cas
c'est est-ce qu'il va pouvoir continuer
à agir au quotidien ou est-ce que ces
mouvements extrêmement puissants sur le
terrain à chacun de ces déplacements
vont créer une forme de neutralisation
de sa capacité à faire autre chose que
s'exprimer à distance via des médias ce
qui pour le coup limiterait un peu sa
capacité d'action et puis la vraie
question c'est la capacité d'action du
gouvernement et là on est toujours
complètement dans l'impasse une majorité
est relative à qui incapable de faire
des alliances vraiment substantielles on
est même on est en doute que ça puisse
arriver même texte par texte et ce qui
fait que finalement on va y revenir je
vous remercie parce que vous me tenez la
perche on va faire ce duel avec cette
question effectivement on va revenir sur
cette allocution du chef de l'État
c'était lundi une question de position
très tranchée sur ce plateau on va faire
un duel Emmanuel Macron a-t-il réussi
son exercice face aux Français ce lundi
deux invités ne sont pas du tout
d'accord d'un côté on a donc Olivier de
l'autre on a pierre et Pierre pour vous
non clairement c'était pas réussi quoi
vous avez 45 secondes expliquez-nous
pourquoi ça vous étonne que j'ai
considéré que j'ai trouvé que le
Président de la République n'est pas
vraiment réussi son son allocution ah
bah non parce que on attendait quand
même beaucoup plus on attendait du
concret on attendait du du de presque ce
que Astrid évoqué c'est-à-dire qu'il y a
un peu plus d'humilité sur on a fait des
erreurs aujourd'hui il va falloir
changer il l'a dit beaucoup on va
changer sur la méthode etc donc on
pouvait pas s'attendre à ce qui nous a
donc autre chose mais c'est vrai qu'à
chaque fois qu'il y a eu une crise il
est à chaque fois sur le devant la scène
avec une proposition ça a été un moment
donné de grand débat ça avait été plutôt
une réussite même si ça avait fait
générer beaucoup de frustration et là il
arrive devant les Français sans rien
véritablement annoncer ni sur la
question sociale qui est quand même au
cœur aujourd'hui des mobilisations
sociales ni même sur la question
climatique est quand même l'urgence du
moment et sans même avoir 11 en début de
de mea culpa sur sur le traumatisme qui
a généré le le meilleur dont on a
outrepassé le Parlement le dialogue
social avec les partenaires sociaux
j'ai pas eu le droit à mon premier tour
de table moi tout à l'heure on va
revenir on va revenir en paroles Olivier
la parole est à vous 45 secondes sacré
morceau en face de vous explique-nous
pour vous
cette allocution c'était pas mal en fait
bien sûr sur le fond il aurait pu avoir
beaucoup plus d'humilité mais c'est vrai
que c'est pas tout à fait le style
d'Emmanuel Macron comment ça peut à le
connaître maintenant il y aurait pu
avoir des regrets autre chose qui soit
un peu différent de en gros on s'est mal
expliqué ce qui est toujours
effectivement une façon un peu
maladroite de le faire mais je crois
quand même que l'exercice c'est une
réussite dans la mesure où il va bien
utiliser les leviers qu'il avait à sa
disposition institutionnellement la
retraite est passée la pilule sans doute
pas du tout mais en tout cas
institutionnellement maintenant les les
syndicats sont devant la difficulté à
continuer un mouvement alors que les
choses sont faites et là où c'est je
trouve très intéressant c'est qu'il ne
lancer sur des pistes qui certes
ressemblaient plus à des pistes qu'on
aurait pu évoquer en campagne
présidentielle des pistes extrêmement
vastes notre rapport au travail
évidemment la réforme de la santé la
sécurité la justice mais du coup ça nous
ça nous lance des eaux et qui fait que
on est tous aujourd'hui partie dans les
débats hyper vaste qu'il a lancé voilà
c'est malin c'est exceptionnellement
quelques secondes de plus c'est votre
première Jean-Luc on attendait beaucoup
cette allocution du chef de l'État
est-ce qu'on en entendait pas un peu
trop
attendait même un peu on avait tort on
est dans une situation qui est
complètement qui est complètement
bloquée le président de la République
c'est intervention elle est dans la dans
la matrice générale d'un d'une
rhétorique qui ne fonctionne plus donc
voilà soit on renverse la table il n'a
pas renversé soit on est toujours à la
même table et on présente des plats qui
sont indigestes qui ne fonctionnent
qu'il ne faut qui ne fonctionne pas quoi
ça marcher
c'est que au bout d'un moment la parole
est aussi la crédibilité de la parole
dépend de l'émetteur et l'émetteur est
abîmé enfin le président de la
République est abîmé mais c'est ce que
je disais tout à l'heure
Jacques Chirac à la fin de son mandat on
faisait pas très attention à ce qu'il
disait
François Hollande peut-être un peu avant
la fin de son mandat on avait fini par
plus faire attention à ce qu'il disait
donc on est dans le début du mandats
tout à l'heure c'est 4 ans ce qui est
frappant avec avec Emmanuel Macron c'est
que c'est un président de mon point de
vue atypique parce qu'il n'a jamais été
mais c'est à dire qu'il n'y a pas eu
d'affect autour de Macron il y a eu des
gens qui l'ont apprécié mais apprécié
comment on apprécie le président du
conseil d'administration de son
entreprise pas comme le chef de l'État
avec toute la toute l'image qu'il y a
autour du chef de l'État il y a pas de
fan club vraiment vraiment structuré en
plus il y a pas de parti politique ça
existe pas c'est un truc c'est un machin
mais ça c'est une voilà c'est ce n'est
pas une formation politique les autres
avaient ce ce fan club le seul avantage
de l'intervention du président de la
République là c'est qu'elle a existé et
que pendant toute une phase toute une
phase pendant un mois et demi les
caméras et l'attention elle était à la
sortie de la terre syndicale d'une
certaine manière il
reprend un peu la main en étant au
milieu du jeu ça veut pas dire qu'il est
approuvé mais ça veut dire qu'il initie
un certain nombre de thèmes ce qu'il ne
pouvait pas faire et qu'il n'a pas voulu
faire pendant toute la période pour lui
peu importe la popularité il dit vouloir
continuer son job écoutez-le la mission
d'un président de la République
n'est ni d'être aimé de ne pas être aimé
c'est d'essayer de faire bien pour son
pays et d'agir et moi je suis au service
des Françaises et des Français je serai
jusqu'au dernier instant du mandat qui
m'ont confié et je le serai par beau
temps et par temps de pluie
voilà Astrid qu'est ce que ça change
qu'Emmanuel Macron soit aujourd'hui un
populaire très concrètement pour la
suite du brexit du quinquennat on peut
en parler de la popularité c'est très
intéressant même si en plus dans les
courbes il est pas si bas c'est ça qui
est assez paradoxal il est François
Hollande à son plus bas été à 13 %,
c'est 10 points de moins donc je crois
que c'est pas le même ressort Hollande
il y avait une forme de déception après
le président normal Emmanuel Macron il y
a de la haine dans les qualitatifs les
sondages qualitatifs c'est bien plus
grave il y avait un rejet aussi de
Nicolas Sarkozy on s'en rappelle oui
c'est vrai mais en fin de mandat plutôt
moi est-ce que je trouve c'est qu'en
fait c'est pas tant être aimé ou pas
être aimé c'est surtout comment on
avance ensemble en fait il est pas
Premier ministre Emmanuel Macron il est
président de la République garant aussi
de l'unité du pays du de notre image à
l'international du fait qu'on qu'il y a
une cohésion sociale donc en fait on se
coupe pas comme ça de tous les et décors
intermédiaires et des Français je je
vois pas en effet les marges de
manoeuvre qui va lui rester parce qu'il
crisse encore plus beaucoup de députés
d'ailleurs notent que c'est depuis le
49-3 en fait que tous ces crispé avant
c'était plus dans les manifs les manifs
déjà été beaucoup plus classiques avec
l'Inter syndicale qui qui gérait à
partir du 49-3 on a ces manifestations
spontanées qui sont donc plus violentes
plus spectaculaires et puis on a surtout
voilà un président de la République qui
se retrouve au centre des critiques
alors qu'avant dans les manifs c'était
encore Élisabeth borne son ministre du
Travail ça se joue à l'Assemblée donc
depuis qu'il a fait ça ça commence à
remonter maintenant et est-ce qu'il
pluie il avance moins il pourra reculer
un jour ou l'autre s'il le faut ces
oppositions pierre vont pas finir par
par se lasser c'est un peu le pari
d'Emmanuel Macron aussi là-dessus je
sais pas si elles vont se lasser je
trouve que celui qui résume assez bien
la situation en ce moment et qu'il le
résume le mieux c'est Laurent Berger il
dit il nous faut un temps de il y a un
temps de décence c'est-à-dire que les
oppositions ont été tellement malmenées
tellement mis sur la touche on l'a vu au
Parlement on l'a vu évidemment dans le
cadre de de ce qu'on appelle la
démocratie sociale c'est de la méthode
c'est à dire la manière dont on tient
compte des organisations syndicales et
cette nécessité du temps de décence
aurait dû aussi être perçu par Emmanuel
Macron
[Musique]
la situation elle a été déjà comme ça
avant le même la réforme des retraites
qu'est-ce que c'est un peu popularité va
changer pour les quatre années qui
restent maintenant les deux péchés
originels du quinquennat sont toujours
là il est arrivé sans vraiment son
programme sans projet je suis désolé il
y a pas eu il y avait rien de clair il y
a rien de très précis le seul truc
c'était à peu près la retraite qu'il a
plus ou moins fait passer 64 ou 65 et
puis la deuxième chose c'est évidemment
tu as une majorité relative c'était
écrit que ce serait difficile depuis le
soir des élections je veux dire on le
savait sauf qu'au départ on aurait pu
supposer que LR aurait pu facilement
faire quelque chose évidemment avec
Renaissance et c'est pas ce qui se passe
pour plein de raisons c'est beaucoup
plus compliqué c'est pas certain
qu'effectivement ça soit simple
d'arriver à faire passer la loi
immigration parce que en gros la gauche
trouvera que c'est trop et la droite
c'est pas assez hein donc vous allez
peut-être ça se trouve vous retrouvez
assez sale et puis il y a pas tellement
d'autres projets les autres ils sont
plutôt sur des projets à très long terme
sans choses précises sur le travail par
exemple la gauche a-t-elle tout ratée
pourquoi n'est-elle pas la grande
gagnante de la colère sociale c'est
notre deuxième thème oui on aurait pu se
dire qu'après 12 journées de
mobilisation à des Français très
remontés la gauche tirait les marrons du
feu et bien non tous les sondages le
montrent c'est Marine Le Pen qui semble
profiter de la crise
rien n'est fait rien n'est fait mais je
pense que d'ici 2027 en tout cas c'est
le parti qui qui prépare vraiment très
sérieusement les élections 2027 et je
pense qu'il a largement sa chance de
passer aux élections 2027 et d'être au
second tour et puis de remporter les
élections ça c'est clair on serait que
dans la vie de tous les jours je
travaille beaucoup sur le chantier et on
discute avec les gens on voit quand même
que l'opinion quand même vachement
changé quoi c'est vrai que les gens qui
votent à gauche
bascule quand même beaucoup vers le
Front national voilà c'était des
partisans de Marine Le Pen dans la Somme
Astrid ça aurait dû être la gauche qui
aurait dû profiter de cette séquence
comme on dit de cette séquence des
retraites c'est pas le cas moi en tout
cas je dirais pas qu'elle a tout raté la
gauche parce que s'il y a des manifs
c'est quand même la gauche qui est dans
la rue le rassemblement national n'y va
pas et puis au Parlement la gauche
notamment socialiste a été quand même
assez présente pour lever des lièvres
comme par exemple les 1200 euros donc
elle est enfin voilà l'Inter syndicale
est unie après je pense que c'est bien
plus profond en fait le l'arrivée
l'émergence l'importance du RN
aujourd'hui dans le pays c'est ça ça
remonte pas de il y a quelques mois ça
fait depuis 2002 on est le 21 avril ça
fait depuis 2002 que voilà que que le
alors
bien avant sa fille avec des idées bien
plus affichées sur l'extrême
et jour de la parole Marine Le Pen
attend en avril 39% d'opinion favorables
c'est un sondage Ipsos pour Le Point
c'est le plus haut niveau jamais
enregistré par ce baromètre pour la chef
de fil du RN et puis cette route et
cette autre étude de la Fondation Jean
Jaurès qui a été publiée au début du
mois le RN est le seul parti politique
qui sort renforcé de la crise si de
nouvelles élections législatives avaient
lieu ils gagneraient 7 points par
rapport à son score de juin 2022
ça rejoint ma question c'est à dire que
il y a eu cette crise sociale très forte
une colère sociale et on voit que c'est
pas c'est pas la gauche qui marque les
points
la nuit pêche c'est le RN sont dans à
l'assemblée qui sont un peu les
nouvelles forces émergentes les deux
blocs qui entourent Emmanuel Macron
n'ont pas du tout les mêmes stratégies
l'une a besoin de se recentrer et donc
de rentrer le plus possible dans les
institutions de la 5e donc joue le jeu à
fond au point de félicite de de apporter
tout son soutien par exemple à Olivier
du socle quand il se fait traiter
d'assassin sur l'autre de l'autre côté
c'est à dire côté elle est fin UPS moi
je crois en effet que ce que ça montre
aussi c'est que le chahut permanent je
suis pas sûr que ce soit à l'Assemblée
je suis pas sûr que les Français
attendent ça Jean-Luc c'est ça c'est la
gauche a commis des erreurs de remarque
depuis le 19e siècle les mouvements
sociaux profitent à la gauche et le
désordre profite à la droite le problème
de LFI c'est qu'il faut les deux
ils animent le mouvement social ils y
participent d'ailleurs souvent en
désaccord avec la stratégie des
organisations syndicales en tout cas de
manière différente des organisations
syndicales au point qu'elle s'en est
neuve mais ils organisent des formes de
désordre dans l'organisation de la
République à l'Assemblée nationale et ça
ça les empêche de bénéficier de la de
l'avantage naturel qu'on va avoir
deuxième raison qui est peut-être plus
profonde c'est qu'aujourd'hui
l'émergence d'un populisme de droite
d'extrême droite fait que la colère
sociale elle ne bénéficie plus de
manière automatique à la gauche puis la
troisième raison c'est que c'est abusif
de parler de la gauche il faudra encore
qu'il y ait une gauche la nuit pêche
aujourd'hui
il y a Mélenchon et sa formation
politique et puis il y a deux trois
formations politiques plus ou moins dans
le syndrome de Stockholm volontaire en
se disant finalement
on fait ce que le chef a décidé même si
ça rechigne etc mais il n'y a pas de
parole singulière dans la diversité de
la gauche française c'est-à-dire est-ce
qu'il y a une parole sociale démocrate
quelque part où aller à la parole
sociale démocrate 75%
à la présidence
on est obligé de plus exister et qu'on
est forcé de d'astiquer ces
il y a une responsabilité de la France
insoumise dans cette entre deux de ce en
même temps à la fois bordélisation à la
fois on mise sur la colère sociale ou
est-ce que je veux dire d'abord qu'on
vous regarde l'histoire vous vous rendez
compte que les victoires des
mobilisations sociales des mots ce qu'on
peut appeler les mobilisations
populaires elles ont mis du temps vous
prenez le Front populaire il y a eu
combien d'années de grève de
mobilisation avant même que le programme
du Front populaire arrive au
gouvernement prenez les mobilisation les
plus grandes de ces dernières années des
95 il a fallu attendre 97 2 ans pour que
la gauche redevienne majoritaire pour
gouverner donc il faut le temps aussi
que les gens comprennent la mobilisation
c'est qu'il se passe ce qui se joue dans
ces populations et que la gauche
effectivement se retrouvent à être en
capacité d'être de porter un projet de
crédible et de d'apparaître comme étant
une alternance possible à Emmanuel
Macron ça c'est la première chose la
deuxième chose il y a quelque chose qui
m'agace mais alors à un point vous
imaginez pas de récit médiatique que
l'on raconte que Marine Le Pen est
formidable à une essence extraordinaire
c'est la plus républicaine d'entre tous
celle qui tire les marrons du feu parce
que les vous êtes si tu as un sondage
très bien le sondage montre que c'est
Marine Le Pen elle qui tire et marron du
feu mais si vous allez un peu plus loin
dans ces sondages vous voyez quoi alors
certes la nupestre ne progresse pas de
manière fulgurante mais la première
force si vous faites si vous fait tester
le sondage sur qui gagnerait les
élections législatives ça serait la nuit
peste d'une courte majorité je vous
l'accorde mais c'est quand même la nups
pourquoi ne le dis pas c'est elle qui a
le plus de voix et celle qui aurait le
plus de siège à l'Assemblée nationale
sans avoir de majorité pour un
personnage sur les personnalités ce
récit médiatique qui consiste à dire
Marine Le Pen est extraordinaire et
personne
mais si on dit tout le temps qu'elle est
responsable quelle est la plus
républicaine
est-ce qu'on oppose l'image de Marine Le
Pen et de ses petits camarades qui n'ont
rien dit pendant la réforme des
retraites il commence tout juste à
sortir du bois en disant nous si on
arrive au pouvoir on fait la réforme
mais on fait la réforme qu'on veut si le
contexte économique nous le permet les
promesses il faut faire attention donc
encore une fois il faut faire attention
au discours que l'on construit parce que
je dis pas vous ici sur cette chaîne
mais sur mais en général nous avons une
responsabilité à avoir une analyse un
peu modérée parce que c'est pas les
trois personnes qui ont fait des
conneries sur les bancs de la France
insoumise qui doivent entacher
l'ensemble de ce qu'a fait la nuit
la gauche est-elle encore le parti le
mouvement de la colère sociale on va le
poser comme ça la question peut-être
plus générale un peu de l'absence
d'offre sociale démocrate effectivement
qui qui se fait vraiment sentir je veux
dire la gauche a laissé
démocratie elle a laissé des classes
populaires elle a laissé l'universalité
la vision du progrès non mais ça fait
quand même beaucoup la laïcité la vision
du progrès le travail tout ça ça a été
laissé alors bon bah ça allait où par
vasque communiquant ailleurs d'autant
plus qu'effectivement la stratégie du
désordre en tout cas elle a donné
mauvaise impression visiblement elle a
plutôt favorisé des gens qui jouent
plutôt l'institution et puis le talent
malheureusement sans doute du RN depuis
le début avant le FN c'était de
cristalliser d'avoir la capacité sans
rien dire en fait c'est ça qui est fou
en restant quasiment sur son canapé tu
cristallise les mécontentement moins tu
parles tu as l'impression et et plus tu
montes donc c'est effectivement c'est
c'est pas juste mais c'est comme ça
alors si on regarde très froidement non
pas les sondages mais les élections je
veux dire pour l'instant le RN c'est
l'histoire d'une irrésistible ascension
voilà je veux dire faut regarder la
dernière élection et puis le sondage
effectivement qui explique au deuxième
tour euh
Marine Le Pen pourra être élu je veux
dire le truc est en train de monter
alors il y a vraiment un problème de
stratégie en tout cas de la part des
oppositions quelle qu'elle soit depuis
40 ans parce que de toute évidence le
compte time menthe ne fonctionne pas
mais c'est intéressant ce que vous dites
c'est que effectivement le rassemblement
national ne fait pas grand-chose en tout
cas pendant cette séquence t'as pas fait
grand-chose comment vous expliquer vous
assed que qu'elle continue de monter
Marine Le Pen en tout cas qu'elle ne
redescend pas mais ça c'est le propre
des formations politiques qu'on n'a
jamais testé et en plus ça s'inscrit
dans un contexte international ou le
populisme d'extrême droite fait des
petits partout donc pourquoi on y
échapperait nous aussi il faut remettre
quand même tout ça en perspective
ensuite je crois aussi que Marine Le Pen
elle a elle incarne elle a déjà été
candidate à la présidentielle trois fois
elle est déjà arrivée au second tour
elle est la dernière fois elle elle a
jamais été aussi haut c'est aussi pour
ça que elle elle engrange alors que
Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui a aussi été
candidat mais pas au second tour lui a
décidé de entre guillemets rendre voilà
raccrocher les gants puisqu'il n'est pas
allé à l'Assemblée nationale je pense ça
a été une erreur stratégique de sa part
parce que il ce fameux discours au soir
du premier tour fête mieux donc c'est ce
qui est très intéressant en terme de de
suite et de succession mais du coup il
remet tout à zéro pour ces petits des
petits jeunes ou moins jeunes d'ailleurs
parce que maintenant il commence à avoir
50 ans qu'il voudrait prendre la suite
donc c'est pas du tout comparable en
terme de moments aussi politiques et
international précisément faut-il des
battre avec l'extrême droite faut-il
confronter nos idées peu importe
l'endroit peu importe le sujet avec la
droite de la droite la question
évidemment n'est pas nouvelle mais une
soirée débat organisée par le magazine
valeur actuelle à Paris a suscité la
polémique cette semaine parmi les
invités vous Olivier babot vous avez
affronté comme on dit le président du RN
Jordan Bardella le journaliste est
militant écologiste Hugo Clément aussi
il s'en explique et je vous donne la
parole juste après
pourquoi j'ai accepté de venir c'est
très simple c'est que je suis persuadé
que les sujets que je porte que je
défends sur lesquels je travaille sont
des sujets qui doivent être pris en
charge par l'ensemble du spectre
politique on va tous être frappé de la
même manière par les phénomènes qui sont
en œuvre on va tous être frappé par le
changement climatique les plus fragiles
les plus pauvres les classes populaires
et il se trouve que l'électorat du
rassemblement national compte beaucoup
de jeunes et comptent beaucoup de
personnes issues des classes populaires
et c'est pour ça que c'est très
important de parler d'écologie avec tout
le monde y compris dans des endroits où
on m'attend pas forcément voilà Olivier
donc vous avez participé à cette cette
soirée à ce débat vous avez vous êtes
intervenu sur l'intelligence
artificielle pourquoi selon vous il faut
débattre avec la droite de la droite
alors déjà le public de valeur actuelle
je considère pas que c'est que des
électeurs du rassemblement national je
sais pas il se trouve que moi j'écris
souvent dans ce canard j'écris dans
beaucoup d'autres canards donc
l'excellent front tireur dans le Figaro
dans les échos mon idée que le problème
en démocratie commence déjà quand on ne
se parle plus déjà il faut aller parler
aux gens moi je veux pas de politique je
me présente pas et j'ai certainement pas
cette cette volonté là mais je pense que
tous les sujets valent le coup et puis
c'est quand vous allez débattre avec les
gens que vous pouvez vous opposer à
leurs arguments et donc moi je sais pas
si le public avait bien compris mais je
vais l'expliquer par exemple en quoi le
programme était complètement à côté de
la plaque à plein de à Paris donc disons
que le Père Noël se transforme très
souvent malheureusement en Père
Fouettard et qu'il fallait pas accepter
les réponses simples à des problèmes qui
sont très compliqués donc je pense que
cette c'est important d'y aller et puis
on parlait tout à l'heure de stratégie
pour contenir le rassemblement national
ça a été hyper efficace de le maintenir
à distance depuis 40 ans tout est
évident ça a été un très très gros
succès donc non je pense qu'il faut y
aller et puis on parlait de sujets
importants à l'écologie certainement
mais il y a du persuadé que le truc est
en train de changer le monde et
bizarrement très peu de gens en parlent
et je leur donne mardala est un des un
des seuls très étonnamment en parler
Astrid vous êtes d'accord il faut aller
débattre dans alors en l'occurrence
c'était un grand débat organisé par le
magazine valeur actuelle qu'est-ce que
vous pensez de la démarche ah non mais
si vous cautionnez ces idées là et que
vous estimez que le RN est un parti
comme les autres bah c'est voilà Hugo
clé vous vous y allez moi je crois que
c'est pas du tout pareil qu'en fait de
débattre par exemple sur un plateau de
télévision parce que cet événement sans
mot Clément on en aurait beaucoup moins
parlé donc en un sens c'est leur donner
le point j'ajoute que ça dépend des
valeurs qu'on défend en fait mais c'est
vrai que si Hugo Clément pense que le RN
va faire de l'écologie je pense qu'il se
trompe et qu'il a mal lu leur programme
je pense aussi que en y allant en fait
en un sens il les aide presque comme ça
c'est une caution en fait donc peut-être
qu'il veut les aider en disant à votre
programme n'est pas assez écolo votre
problème n'est pas assez bon bah c'est
peut-être son choix politique en tout
cas c'est ce que ça ça renvoie et en
même temps c'est ce que dit Olivier
Jean-Luc c'est une manière comment on
fait changer d'avis certains électeurs
certaines personnes si on dialogue pas
si on ne débat pas avec eux
moi je suis très très circonspect en
fait sur la réponse à cette question
elle est elle est pas elle est pas si
facile que ça
d'abord sur le cadre évidemment
aller parler devant ce public là malgré
tout je suis désolé de le dire à notre
ami mais c'est à comme aller parler de
démocratie devant s'imposionne du Parti
communiste chinois enfin il y a peu de
chance de convaincre les gens qui sont
là de ces valeurs là oui mais oui on
peut essayer mais en même temps
peut-être de temps en temps non non
des convertis donc premièrement le cadre
ça se discute deuxièmement est-ce qu'il
faut parler aux électeurs du
rassemblement national évidemment oui il
faut les il faut les il faut essayer de
les reconquérir essayer de leur
expliquer et essayer de les de les
gagner de l'autre côté c'est pas faire
dur en même temps mais je suis sensible
à l'argument de la banalisation parce
que si on dit on discute avec eux comme
avec les autres on accepte l'idée que
c'est une alternance possible comme les
autres or ça n'est pas une alternance
possible comme les autres la présence
l'arrivée au pouvoir du rassemblement
national c'est pas une alternance c'est
une rupture fondamentale avec ce qui
fonde les valeurs républicaines l'État
de droit les traditions
un pays qui vit sur les valeurs des
lumières donc on est dans une forme de
rupture et donc c'est très difficile à
manier parce que évidemment il faut
parler il faut débattre il faut défendre
des idées c'est ce qu'on fait pour
terminer moi ce qui m'inquiète le plus
c'est pas qu'on aille débattre avec le
Front national c'est la tendance à agir
comme le Front national que font les
pouvoirs de gauche comme de droite
peut-être plus que de droite que ceux de
gauche depuis maintenant des années et
un peu partout en Europe c'est la
contagion intellectuelle qui a atteint
l'action de nos pouvoirs politiques
enfin vous pourriez organiser un débat
avec certains militants de la droite de
la droite de l'extrême droite ce que
c'est un problème de débattre non
clairement non le politisme invitera pas
de personnes ils ont suffisamment voie
au chapitre dans bien des médias pour
avoir besoin de politesse pour le faire
et est-ce que vous serez vous allez non
je ne serai pas de valeur actuelle je
partage entièrement ce que vous venez de
dire mais alors sur la totalité c'est un
débat qui est compliqué l'extrême droite
et absolument colossal donc on peut pas
ne pas en tenir compte par les électorat
de l'extrême droite évidemment il faut
le faire en revanche là où il y a un
problème sur le sujet que vous
introduisez dans cette dans cette
émission c'est effectivement le cas Hugo
Clément qui décide d'aller porter une
parole devant un public convaincu par
des thèses parfois racistes en tout cas
minimax xénophobe souvent et qui ne sont
pas sans lien avec les questions
écologiques et c'est le problème mais
que pose aujourd'hui Hugo Clément qui
est quand même une personnalité du
service public français qui est membre
qui journaliste sur France Télévisions
qui viennent donner une caution écolo à
cet espace là à cet endroit là ça ça me
pose un problème parce que ce qu'il n'a
pas dit dans ce débat pour lequel j'ai
vu une partie de de son discours c'est
que on a une responsabilité de nous
aujourd'hui dans les dérèglements
climatiques du monde et donc ça ne peut
pas être sans lien avec l'accueil des
réfugiés que refusent l'extrême droite
aujourd'hui et c'est ça qui est
problématique c'est que dans le discours
de Monsieur Hugo Clément il dit là ils
sont en train de parler de choc des
civilisations machin blablabli tout ça
tout ça on s'en fout parce que l'enjeu
c'est la question écolo c'est la
question de la survie du peuple du
peuple terrestre de la faute de l'or et
ça c'est un problème de tenir ce genre
de discours là-bas donc il donne une
caution à ces gens-là Olivier est-ce que
vous avez donné vous aussi une caution à
ces gens-là comme dit je crois pas qu'il
y ait pas de qui est des sous électeurs
et que il faille pas s'adresser à des
gens qui ont quand même voté à 40% des
frais est-ce que le problème c'est pas
le lieu le problème c'est peut-être
d'aller à ce débat c'est un parti je
suis désolé il s'inscrit aujourd'hui
dans la dans la dans la dans la
République il y a une constitution Dieu
soit à louer il y a des institutions
jusqu'à aux dernières nouvelles il y a
pas de projet que que ça se passe c'est
un parti normal si on veut c'est un
parti normal aujourd'hui on peut pas
exclure que que le Front national prenne
le pouvoir pas prêt de pouvoir au sens
soit élu je veux dire 89
aujourd'hui c'est qu'est-ce je ferai
vraiment qu'est-ce qui pourrait faire
quels sont les limites auditionnelles
qu'est-ce qu'il y a vraiment dans le
programme la
constitutionnelle sur la priorité
nationale
de deux tiers au Parlement tout compris
donc ça me paraît un peu compliqué
d'ailleurs est-ce que Marine Le Pen élu
mais est-ce qu'ils ont une majorité
c'est pas tout à fait sûr en tout cas
aujourd'hui il y a 89 députés c'est une
vérité qu'il faut passer une réalité
qu'il faut prendre et moi je pense que
plus on tourne le dos plus on fait
l'autruche moi on parle moi on s'oppose
moi on dit mais le programme là
dites-nous plus
ne laissez pas le silence ben c'est plus
on laisse des gens y croire donc prêcher
des convertis j'adore encore une fois
mais il faut de temps en temps aller
essayer d'aller Jean-Luc
Jean-Luc quand même parce que je trouve
que participer au débat etc c'est une
question de journaliste en réalité au
fond c'est pas fond c'est pas
fondamental ce qui a été dit tout à
l'heure et absolument décisif
quand vous dites
en fait pour un certain nombre
d'écologie
l'important c'est qu'il y ait de
l'écologie et peu importe le reste
c'est formidable c'est à dire que à ce
moment-là Pétain était extraordinaire
des premiers qui a fait le retour à la
terre les valeurs etc donc c'était et
donc on se dit à ce moment-là ces
écologistes-là
formidable enfin ils sont d'accord avec
Zemmour sur ce point-là enfin pas
surtout mais au moins sur ce sur ce sur
ce point-là et donc voilà et donc je
veux dire que
la qualité d'écologie ne suffit pas
résumé le schéma politique pour dire les
choses un peu plus brutalement un
fasciste écologiste ça reste un fasciste
est-ce qu'on se poserait la même
question si le débat va être organisé
par un groupe muscu ou un parti
d'extrême gauche
parce que donc du coup c'est qui qui
pour vous l'extrême gauche Steve je
parle de Lutte Ouvrière par exemple je
parle de certains partis proches du NPA
qu'est-ce que est-ce que on aurait eu le
même débat
vous voyez bien qu'aujourd'hui ils
organisent des des grands meetings il y
a des il y a le il y a les grandes fêtes
de Lutte Ouvrière ou bien des invités
sont présents je ne crois pas que ça
pose de problématiques que ce soit on a
quand même d'un côté un camp quand même
qui se revendique de l'humanisme et de
l'autre un camp qui se revendique quand
même de l'exclusion de la du repli sur
soi des frontières de la souveraineté
nationale conduit à souvent souvent des
rimes on peut pas mettre sur le même
plan je sais bien qu'en ce moment il y a
un jeu assez vous encore une fois mais
j'entends beaucoup dire ah mais que nous
répondit si ça avait été l'extrême
gauche en mettant évidemment la France
insoumise que vous venez de pas faire
dans l'extrême gauche non on peut pas
mettre les deux sur le même plan il y a
pas la même histoire et la même culture
surtout politique et les mêmes
aspirations à vouloir changer la vie des
gens puis on a un journal pardon va
leurs actuelles qui a été condamné pour
un bien sûr raciste récemment à
l'encontre de la députée elle est fit
Daniel obeno qui avait été des peintres
en esclaves vous faites l'équivalence
vous Olivier j'ai pas du tout la même
vision des extrêmes je pense que nous
pour la ficelle extrême gauche et que
c'est
dans leur façon dans la gratitude
vis-à-vis de la démocratie des
institutions sont absolument pas
humanistes je pense que ni près ni de
loin c'est absolument une blague c'est
des gens qui s'y prenaient le pouvoir
feraient les choses une façon assez
terrifiante et là historiquement
malheureusement il y a tellement
d'exemples donc moi je suis désolé en
tant que libérale j'ai peur de tous les
trucs totalisant qui veulent vous faire
le bien contre vous y compris au prix de
votre mort et voilà historiquement je
crois que tout ça a donné beaucoup de
preuves qu'il fallait faire très
attention donc moi je suis au milieu
terrorisé entre les deux voilà on va
jouer un peu si vous voulez les amis on
va faire redescendre un peu l'attention
sur ce plateau on passe à la rubrique
fake news ou pas je vous donne une info
ou quelque chose qui ressemble à une
information vous me dites si c'est vrai
ou si c'est faux la suite de la fair
Playboy je sais pas si vous avez suivi
comme vous le savez la ministre Marlène
Schiappa a fait la une de la revue de
charme ça a suscité quelques réactions
pour le moins étonné notamment de la
part d'Isabelle Rome la ministre en
charge de l'égalité homme-femme qui a
déclaré que ce n'était pas la meilleure
façon de faire avancer la cause des
femmes Marlène Schiappa n'a pas du tout
apprécié la critique elle lui a donc
voyez le joli message suivant tu n'es
qu'à sac à main de seconde main c'est
une vraie information ou si tu ne fake
news
mais que c'est pas celui-là ah c'est
lequel alors je l'ai pas eu mais il
paraît qu'il est pire c'est une
information qui a été révélée par Le
Canard Enchaîné effectivement de cette
semaine tu n'es qu'à 5 à main de seconde
main trouve le courage de me rappeler
plutôt que de parler dans mon dos autre
sujet les députés devraient bientôt
examiner une proposition de loi pour
lutter contre la discrimination
capillaire Jean-Luc l'idée est pas pour
vous l'idée et d'interdire toute
distinction au travail à l'école fondé
sur la texture la couleur la longueur ou
le style capillaire d'un individu pierre
fake news ou pas totalement vrai
c'est une vraie information ça vous
semble pertinent aussi de lutter contre
ou alors vraiment je me suis fait avoir
mais j'ai lu
j'ai lu j'ai entendu le sénateur qui a
fait cette proposition c'est un député
Olivier Serval député l'iode décidément
on a des journalistes d'un tel niveau
qu'aujourd'hui cette rubrique ne
fonctionne pas on va terminer avec cette
annonce d'Emmanuel Macron passer un peu
inaperçu dans son allocution le chef de
l'État a reconnu qu'un consensus sur la
retraite à 64 ans n'avait pas pu être
trouvé il a dit il dit en avoir tiré les
conséquences et a promis que ceux qui
mourront avant 64 recevront une
indemnité de compensation est-ce que
c'est une fake news ou pas Olivier ah
c'est très intéressant parce que ça
pourrait quasiment être une bonne idée
mais non je pense pas parce que on a
besoin de ces gens quand même qui qui
meurent un peu plus tôt parce que ils
payent les gens qui meurent plus tard
donc le système assurantiel fait que ça
te paraît très compliqué d'un point de
vue budgétaire c'est une fake news mais
une bonne idée c'est ce que c'est ce que
vous dites c'est une fake news de nos
amis du gorafia
pour avoir une indemnité ça me semble
moyennement bonne malgré parce que il y
a il y a des réflexions vraiment sur en
fait des espèces de rente qui vont être
servis à des gens mais s'il meurent
plutôt c'est rendu à leur famille parce
que ça veut dire qu'ils auraient payé
trop par rapport à ce qui a été versé
donc c'est pas complètement délirant du
point de vue du système assurentiel mais
direct la mort et évidemment c'est pas
très voilà pas très direction Rome ou
Georgia Meloni fête cette semaine c'est
6 mois à la tête du Conseil italien les
dirigeants d'extrême droite est une
héritière revendiquée du fascisme de
Mussolini son arrivée au pouvoir en
octobre était redouté un peu partout en
Europe et dans le monde ces derniers
jours à la décrété l'état d'urgence
migratoire dans le pays est promis plus
de fermeté contre les passeurs écoutez
et créer donc un autre moyen de lutter
contre les trafiquants d'êtres humains
et de faire passer le message qu'il est
déconseillé d'entrer illégalement en
Italie
cela ne vaut pas la peine de payer les
passeurs non conviennent n'est pas
conseillé de risquer de mourir parce que
les possibilités sont moindres pour ceux
qui entre illégalement en payant les
passeurs que pour ceux qui ne le font
pas
qui
ont été prononcés à la suite d'un
naufrage d'un bateau de migrants qui a
fait plus de 70 morts près des côtes du
sud de l'Italie Jean le Conseil habitué
à ce ton très offensif sur les migration
partout on est on est même tenté de le
comment dire de le mettre dans nos lois
en France ce dont là donc il y a une
tendance honnêtement elle remonte à
tellement longtemps
avec une abdication générale sur cette
question des principes fondamentaux qui
commencent avec la France ne peut pas
supporter toute la misère du monde
il y a 30 ans déjà ou voilà par le parti
politique qui était censé être un
barrage dans la classe ouvrière
là-dessus
contre des foyers d'immigrés à
Ivry ou Vitry je me souviens plus la
ville donc on voit bien que
tout le monde et ceux qu'on avait la
première responsabilité on abdiqué sur
une normalisation de cette extrême
droite
mais il faut remarquer malgré tout pour
ceux qui sont tenté par ce discours fort
que l'arrivée de Madame de la première
ministre italienne d'extrême droite
Mélanie
se réclamant de Mussolini ça n'a pas
fait baisser l'arrivée des immigrés sur
le la terre la terre italienne ça montre
bien que les discours forts que les
mesures les policiers les fils de fer
barbelés les murs en réalité ne sont pas
adaptés ne sont pas aux situations j'ai
envie de dire heureusement à gérer un
problème bien plus fondamental qui fait
que quand des gens sont dans la guerre
risquent leur vie quand des gens sont
dans la misère et qu'ils ont faim ils
bougent et ils se déplace et l'histoire
de l'humanité et c'est pas en faisant
des petits décrets ou en s'excitant
comme elle le fait que sa règle le
problème c'est que c'est devenu une chef
d'État comme une autre en Europe parce
que vous êtes d'accord non pas du tout
non je crois pas
c'est la le chef d'État en Europe sous
peine d'inventaire il doit y avoir un
Hongrie qui traîne ou quelques autres
alors est-ce que c'est une dirigeante
comme une autre aujourd'hui vous dites
que non mais c'est un laboratoire
l'Italie souvent en politique on le dit
souvent là c'est le cas sur l'extrême
droite au pouvoir et je moi ce que je
note c'est surtout la grande hypocrisie
et le grand paradoxe en fait de ce de ce
pouvoir de ce qu'on envoie pour
l'instant
typiquement de faire soi-disant de
pleurer soi-disant sur ses 60 morts en
Méditerranée devant les côtes italienne
alors même que Georgia Meloni prend des
décrets pour empêcher le sauvetage en
mer et empêcher les ONG de de les
secourir c'est voilà il y a pas plus
hypocrite que ça et même chose avec son
ministre de l'Agriculture qui qui
explique qu'il a besoin de main d'oeuvre
mais qui veut surtout pas de
remplacement ethnique donc on est en
plein dans le grand remplacement et dans
ces tests il n'y a pas de réaction à
l'international ou pratiquement pas
c'est pour ça
là vous auriez les bateaux Méditerranée
plein de bateaux et puis l'humanité
évidemment nécessaire qui oblige à aider
les gens qui sont qui sont en danger
est-ce que Pierre cette banalisation de
l'extrême droite l'extrême droite poste
fasciste en l'occurrence avec Jean
jamais le nid marque une rupture en
Europe parce qu'on sait un peu habitué
qu'on ne réagit plus à finalement est-ce
qu'elle peut dire est-ce qu'elle peut
proposer je vais peut-être vous montrer
ce qu'elle ce qu'elle propose et les
mesures adoptées par le gouvernement
Meloni depuis octobre elle a notamment
d'électricité je le disais tout à
l'heure un état d'urgence migratoire qui
prévoit des mesures extraordinaires sans
passer par le vote du Parlement elle
prévoit aussi des peines alourdies
contre les passeurs ou encore
l'interdiction au couplement parentaux
d'enregistrer leurs enfants à l'état
civil pierre je vous donne la maladie
effectivement les mesures mais cette
cette indifférence qu'on remarque en
Europe parce que ça marque une rupture
par rapport à une tradition européenne
depuis la Deuxième Guerre mondiale
d'abord je vais vous offrir un
abonnement à tous et à toutes à politics
parce qu'on a suivi les premiers pas de
Georgia Meloni en Italie et évidemment
l'extrême droite reste l'extrême droite
on parle de la question migratoire et je
vais y revenir mais vous prenez la
question des droits et des libertés les
droits des homosexuels les droits des
femmes les restrictions à l'avortement
les restrictions aux pilules tout ça
c'est dans le package de l'extrême
droite et ça d'ailleurs ça c'est quand
même assez révélateur qui est
effectivement on en dise pas plus que ça
on l'a entendu aux États-Unis ça fait
beaucoup de bruit mais elle nous porte
en Italie les femmes notamment dans le
sud ont de plus en plus de mal à pouvoir
avoir recours à l'avortement et une fois
une fois une fois cela dit sur la
question migratoire beaucoup de gens ont
été dit et effectivement et elle va
durcir les conditions d'accès sur le
territoire italien surtout ce qu'elle va
durcir c'est la possibilité pour les
personnes qui sont arrivées sur le
territoire de pouvoir bénéficier d'un
accompagnement de sanitaires de pouvoir
bénéficier d'apprentis de de cours en
italien etc mais une fois qu'on a dit ça
effectivement ce qui est étonnant avec
le personnage Meloni c'est que elle qui
faisait des grands discours en disant
vous allez voir avec mes petits bras moi
j'ai les les
européenne comment je vais aller
l'affronter mais vous regardez ce
qu'elle fait elle accepte tout ce que
lui demande
l'Union européenne parce qu'elle veut
100 milliards de relance il faut qu'elle
fasse une cure d'austérité c'est ce à
quoi elle s'était engagée évidemment à
ne pas faire et la raison pour laquelle
d'ailleurs Marine Le Pen c'est un peu
distancé de son ami Mélanie c'est aussi
parce que elle accepte les règles qui
lui sont imposées par l'Union européenne
c'est assez voilà c'est extrême droite
aujourd'hui et qui est arrivé au pouvoir
et celle dont se revendiquer Marine Le
Pen on se rend bien compte
qu'effectivement l'Union européenne
qu'on tape en permanence parce que c'est
la méchante qui ne permet pas d'assumer
une forme de souveraineté populaire ben
madame Meloni est devenue presque une
Européenne convaincue européenne est
parfois un bon bouclier pour éviter les
dérives nationales nationalistes parler
de l'Italie on parlait beaucoup de ça on
en parle encore beaucoup d'Italie de
l'Italie comme d'un laboratoire
politique est-ce que vous êtes d'accord
est-ce que ce qui se passe en Italie
aujourd'hui peut-être va être
transposable en France avec extrême
droite qui monte au détriment d'une
droite plus traditionnelle écoutez même
si moi le mot de laboratoire m'effraie
toujours parce que même si c'est
contestable je préfère quand même qu'on
fasse les expériences sur les animaux
plutôt que sur les êtres humains même si
c'est la tendance d'un certain nombre de
gens qui utilisent c'est cette cette
idée donc la France c'est la ses
caractéristiques et jusqu'à maintenant
elle a été l'un des rares pays
finalement va finir par pas pouvoir se
dire rare qui qui non seulement a tenu
bon face à l'extrême droite en terme
électoral et qui en plus a une classe
politique droite comprise droites
comprise qui est très rare dans en
Europe et dans le monde qui a résisté à
ça merci Chirac dans une certaine mesure
merci Sarkozy même s'il y a eu des
porosités idéologiques sur le plan
politique électoral sur la question
fondamentale de l'Alliance c'est c'est
un pays qui a dont la classe politique
résister à
cette à cette tentation donc je ne suis
pas sûr que ce qui se passe dans le
laboratoire italien arrive dans la
réalité française autre sujet cette
semaine la Pologne a marqué le 80ème
anniversaire du soulèvement du ghetto de
Varsovie c'était le 19 avril 1943 ce
jour-là plusieurs centaines de
combattants ont pris les armes contre
les forces nazis mercredi des cérémonies
ont eu lieu et pour la première fois un
président allemand a pris la parole
devant le monument aux héros du ghetto
écoutez
je me tiens de vous aujourd'hui et je
vous demande pardon pour les crimes que
des Allemands ont commis ici les crimes
terribles qui me remplissent d'une onde
profonde
mais c'est aussi avec gratitude et
humilité que je participe à cette
commémoration en tant que premier chef
d'État allemand à le faire
pendant ce temps là les réseaux sociaux
deviennent toujours plus fous on va voir
cette image qui a beaucoup circulé cette
semaine au niveau une visiteuse qui
prend la pose tout sourire sur les rails
maintenant au camp d'Auschwitz un
million de personnes ont été acheminées
par cette route au bout de cette route
évidemment l'extermination on va pas
débattre vraiment de ce sujet évidemment
mais quelle est votre première réaction
Olivier quand vous vous avez vu cette
photo circuler sur les réseaux sociaux
j'étais persuadé que c'était une photo
qui avait été créée par midjorn vous
savez c'est une intelligence
artificielle qui crée des photos un peu
absurdes comme ça comme le pape en
doudoune etc et je me suis dit tiens
c'est un truc qui a été créé tout en
fait non j'ai pas su que c'était une
vraie photo en fait ça ça traduit ce
qu'on sait en fait sur cette culture du
du selfie en fait on voyage dans des
endroits dont on ne comprend pas le sens
et on se prend en photo soi-même dessus
pour se persuader soi-même qu'on y a été
en fait donc je pense que c'est le fruit
de l'ignorance en fait tout simplement
d'être capable je suis même pas sûr
qu'il a méchanceté vous voyez dans ce
genre de l'ignorance
où on est ce qu'on fait on nous a dit
vais pas aller là c'est un lieu
important on y va en ce moment en photo
et puis voilà en pierre oui moi j'ai pas
envie d'être avec un blanc vis-à-vis de
cette génération parce que les pas
responsable de ce qu'on leur a
enseignait elle est pas responsable de
ce que leurs parents parfois n'ont pas
nécessairement les outils les
connaissances historiques de ce qui
s'est passé c'est un problème
d'éducation
je sais plus dans quel pays il y a eu un
stage qui a été fait quand même assez
flippant qui est quand même consiste à
dire que près des deux tiers ou pas des
deux tiers moins des deux tiers je crois
des des moins de 18 ans croient dans les
tests complotistes sur la Shoah qui
n'aurait jamais existé enfin voilà donc
du coup ça c'est quand même un véritable
problème c'est un l'éducation la
question d'éducation et moi je
m'inquiète comment quand en France on
voit les cours d'histoire un peu les le
nombre d'horaires enseignés en histoire
10 minutes et deux l'apprentissage aussi
dès le niveau squelette de l'école sur
des réseaux des réseaux sociaux de
l'usage des réseaux sociaux toutes les
informations les contre-Informations les
fake news qui passent sur les réseaux
sociaux y compris d'ailleurs sur les
questions comme des questions
historiques liées à la choix par exemple
participe effectivement à créer une
génération qui sait plus très bien ce
qui est le vrai du faux donc je pense
qu'il y a de la nécessité de
réintroduire plus plus de
d'enseignements à l'esprit critique dans
les dans l'espace
l'éducation de l'école joue encore son
rôle on va voir ce sondage pour le JDD
qui était publié en septembre 2022 26
86% des jeunes Français ont déjà entendu
parler de la Shoah mais 21 % estime que
la Shoah est un événement daté dans
l'enseignement ne devrait plus être une
priorité Astrid sur cette photo et sur
ce sondage toujours la même question
quand on quand on vous avait vu circuler
cette photo vous êtes dit c'est un
problème d'éducation c'est un problème
plus général des réseaux sociaux et de
la société dans laquelle on est
aujourd'hui non moi ça a été en deux
temps parce qu'au début j'ai cru que
c'était un selfie j'allais dire un peu
classique et je me suis étonné que il y
a un scandale sur un selfie d'ailleurs
le mémorial de juvis n'autorise les
selfies le problème c'est cette photo et
moi elle me met très mal à l'aise cette
photo parce que pour avoir jamais été
aux jeunes mais je suis allé à Yade
vachement en Israël qui est un mémorial
de la joie j'ai été dans un état que je
suis arrivé même pas à raconter ici ou
je comprends même pas comment on en
arrive à faire à poser de cette manière
sur ces lieux là après qu'est-ce que ça
dit c'est pas pour la câble et du tout
mais qu'est-ce que ça dit c'est que ce
voyage il est pas préparé où il est mal
préparé et moi ce qui m'inquiète en fait
c'est qu'on va arriver à un moment il y
aura plus de survivants il y aura plus
de mémoire vivante et donc c'est ça
qu'il faut travailler collectivement là
on prépare l'émission j'ai vu qu'il y
avait une journée nationale en mémoire
des victimes de l'Holocauste le 27
janvier je sais pas qui est au courant
de ce cette journée par exemple moi je
l'ai pas vu passer cette année donc je
pense que ça c'est aussi au pouvoir
public de travailler sur les musées les
expos les films il y en a des films
voilà peut-être mettre plus enfin voilà
encore plus alors que le temps passe
en mémoire en fait ce sujet là c'est la
méconnaissance de l'histoire ou l'esprit
provocation Jean-Luc et c'est l'air du
temps hélas moi je suis allé il y a
encore deux ans
à Auschwitz et birkanao et j'ai vu des
choses moins choquantes que ça mais
identique dire des gens qui mangent
on des sandwichs qui boive une bière
qui s'assoit sur des endroits où même en
rêve il est il est inimaginable de
pouvoir s'asseoir et et c'est vrai que
le premier réflexe on a c'est je dis
franchement c'est envie de les gifler à
toute voler et c'est évidemment pas la
solution c'est de réfléchir à pourquoi
on est arrivé là c'est parce que
il y a un fond d'air révisionniste
idéologiquement c'est à dire que tout se
vaut
alors ça passe par par des choses
multiples c'est-à-dire que on les
prépare pas donc ils vont là comme s'ils
allaient voir la Tour Eiffel ou s'ils
allaient voir le Grand Canyon il y a pas
tous je pense non évidemment pas tous il
y a beaucoup de gens respectueux on
parle de ces exceptions là mais elles
sont tellement insensées que c'est bien
d'en parler donc il y a et puis il y a
un autre révisionnisme c'est les
révisions des des politiques des parfois
des intellectuels enfin écoutez on est
dans un pays où il en a pu dire pendant
des mois que
Pétain avait sauvé les Juifs de France
on est dans un pays où un moment donné
quand un type est trop à gauche on dit
c'est un stalinien
installignan quand un type est trop à
droite on dit que tu es un nazi
c'est-à-dire que la spécificité dans le
20e siècle de ces deux horreurs
fondamentales aujourd'hui elles sont
révisées d'une certaine mesure par
l'usage par l'absence d'éducation par
les défauts de l'éducation et c'est ça
qui me paraît extraordinaire
extraordinairement grave et qui sans
doute amen au fait que on puisse
s'asseoir enfin sur les rails de
l'endroit où arriver des convois de gens
dont une grande partie allait se faire
exterminer dans des chambres à gaz par
un processus
criminel jamais vu dans l'histoire de
l'humanité jamais vu dans l'histoire de
l'humanité Olivier en quelques secondes
pour vous c'est aussi le contexte
politique actuel qui peut expliquer ce
genre de photo
je sais pas parce que effectivement
c'est plus l'air du temps je pense que
c'est beaucoup de choses moi les stades
dont on a parlé me font phrases dans le
dos 86 % qui ont déjà entendu parler tu
veux dire 14 % jamais entendu parler
mais dans quel monde ils ont vécu en
fait à quel moment tu peux vivre et être
éduqué et pas avoir cette donnée
essentielle dans ta culture générale il
y a quand même une question que je me
pose alors est-ce que c'est le nombre de
d'histoire est-ce que est-ce qu'on en
parle passé j'ai l'impression qu'il y a
plein d'émissions qui a plein de choses
des documentaires il y a des films je
sais pas ce qu'il faut faire mais de
toute évidence il y a quand même un
manque important voilà comme chaque
semaine on va terminer cette émission
par un top flop je vous pose une
question simple qui a marqué l'actualité
de la semaine en bien ou en match je
suis désolé pour la transition Jean-Luc
mais quelle est votre top et votre flop
de cette semaine je commence par le top
parce que je franchement je me suis
étonné en le trouvant ça m'arrive
rarement mais je trouve que Darmanin a
raison sur l'histoire de la limitation
des points retirés sur les permis de
conduire parce que quand on voit que il
y a tant de gens qui disent
on a fait un tout petit excès on est
emmerdé pour le travail je trouve que
bon voilà c'est pas parce que c'est
Darmanin il le fait c'est
plutôt bien le flop c'est la décision du
tribunal de Marseille
condamnant à l'éligibilité avec effet
immédiat Hubert Falco le maire de Toulon
l'histoire a pas beaucoup d'intérêt
Hubert Falco Rossia président du conseil
départemental continue à aller manger
gratuitement comme les élus ont droit à
la cantine c'est des repas à 2 euros 30
il y va le Tribunal considère qu'il faut
le condamner à 5 ans de trois ans de
prison ferme 5 ans d'idées et une amende
très bien mais il décide l'application
immédiate de l'inégibilité il doit
rendre ses mandats immédiatement ce qui
veut dire un qu'on a plus d'appel qui
sert plus à rien c'est-à-dire qu'on
détruit la logique française qui fait
que on a le droit pour ça qu'on a nation
d'avoir un appel il appelle il existe il
appelle des suspensives en général là il
les pâtes et deuxièmement quand même je
me dis est-ce que j'ai vraiment délégué
à des magistrats qui sont là parce
qu'ils ont reçu un concours certes
difficile mais c'est jamais qu'un
concours est-ce que je l'aurais délégué
le droit de choisir de m'interdire de
voter pour quelqu'un donc sur le
principe de ligne égébéité votre top et
votre flop de la semaine moi j'ai deux
flops allez-y j'ai peut-être joué à la
vie en noir mais alors d'abord c'est sur
les entreprises les faillites qui
repartent les conférences
les parents les familles ils parlent les
faillites pardon repartent à la hausse
de 14000 défaillances d'entreprise
c'était une des un des doutes qu'on
avait est-ce que le quoi qu'il en coûte
à pas créer des formes d'entreprise
zombies qui une fois que tu enlèves le
quoiqu'il en coûte risque risque de
choir la deuxième le deuxième flop c'est
la guerre de l'information de
l'objectivité qui est lancé avec Elon
Musk et qui qualifie qualifié sur donc
Twitter à travers Twitter la BBC de
public lit fin de média l'idée étant de
le mettre en relation avec ce qu'on dit
sur les médias chinois par exemple et
donc ça fait une sorte de relativisme
dans les informations qui font que
justement on en parlait ça favorise
l'idée de tout ce veau tout est biaisé
donc ma vérité est la bonne quoi pierre
15 secondes top d'abord je vous remercie
Théo qui est le stagiaire de 3e qu'on a
accueilli à Poitiers c'est qu'il m'a
aidé à préparer mon top flop
va à Sandrine Rousseau qui propose
d'aller plus loin dans la nups et je
pense qu'elle a raison il faut des
accords notamment aux européennes comme
elles sont que vous le vouloir et mon
flop va à créer mon beau ne qui cherche
sa gauche visiblement et qui cherche sa
sortie de piste du gouvernement pour
revenir sur le terrain politique mais
sans doute au niveau local Astrid 15
secondes aussi top flop moi mon flop
c'est Bruno Le Maire qui dans moi je
trouve que c'est des mesures
démagogiques qui ont été annoncées cette
semaine et qui a dit qu'il voulait
lutter contre
sociale et en visant les pays du Maghreb
je pense que ça ça rejoint tout ce qu'on
a dit aujourd'hui c'est à dire qu'il
donne le point à Marine Le Pen mon top
c'est le petit groupe liotte dont on
n'aurait pas pensé à l'Assemblée qu'on
s'y intéresserait aussi de deux cyprès
qui fait qui va faire voter une
proposition de loi le 8 juin pourra ou
non abroger le texte sur les retraites
merci à tous les quatre d'y avoir
participé salut à vous d'ailleurs votre
écran me dit dans l'oreillette que vous
êtes fidèle et nombreux merci vous
pouvez nous revoir en replay et en
podcast n'hésitez pas on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine même jour même heure
et même endroit à bye
[Musique]